he is one of the best to ever lace them
up in the National Football League
joining me here once again on the
program but for the first time as the
official Rich Eisen show SP red carpet
correspondent is he was so kind to be
last night good to see you again Terrell
Owens thanks for having me how was it
how was the experience we good it was
good i enjoyed it uh kind of being on
the other side of the fence yeah kinda
sorta and uh yeah I mean it was a little
warm but it was manageable part of the
paparazzi well yeah yeah yeah everybody
was asking me had I crossed you know
cross sides and wood right and what did
you say you said I said not just yet not
just you not just it okay and so who did
you who did you you spoke to ronda
rousey right I did I did what was that
like for you I mean I was mesmerised I
was hoping I didn't say anything wrong
and she clocked me right on the spot
right but no no she had a little short
with a short stint you know with her but
uh yeah she's she's an amazing athlete
right and she won a couple of awards Oh
best best fighter well cheap one best
fighter / g heard what you said about
Floyd right did you hear what you said
no I didn't do we have that sound I did
it's not one of it run ronda rousey at
it she cuz she wins the best fighter
award and she gets it on the red carpet
I guess either before ever she all right
warden all I did see her come through
the red carpet and they had an SP
already okay yes so she that was what it
was she would already received the best
fighter award it was given out before
and she beat floyd mayweather only do
that and this is her response Oh take a
take a watch Wow well um I can't help
but but i really say that I wonder how
Floyd feels being beat by a woman for
once well I can see a pretend to not
know who I am now
ha ha ha ha wow wow how about that game
oh my gosh I'm sure there will be a
response up there might be but what I
mean make you gotta respect that sort of
game right there absolutely absolutely i
mean for her to do what she's done i
mean it's it's an amazing feat I mean
and so who did you want to interview on
the red carpet that unfortunately didn't
come by our spot t.o.o there was a lot I
mean uh like got like LeBron I wanted to
get him on the carpet obviously a lot of
those guys they kind of just showed up
went straight into the venue Andre
Iguodala he he kind of dodged me look
what do you mean he gave me a stiff arm
he was just too cool for school what's
that all about oh no no I gave him a
little stuff about it you've got more
Philadelphia time and then he did right
now on you you were with the Eagles
longer than he was with the Sixers know
there's are the Sixers for a while was
he really yeah he's there eight nine
years okay III got no home a little bit
you know baggies like me and I didn't
see he's like my people were having me
going this way that way what I landed on
his feet yeah and I was like dude I said
you were standing there kind of just
looking around and then he's like no my
bad my bad ah but you know it's an
assessment with one finals MVP I I mean
that's how it is you know you win a
Finals MVP over you know a guy that
could have been the MVP and Steph Curry
then you know but draymond Green
explained why he dogged him though what
he said Iguodala was a big Niners fan
and with teal left oh yeah he said he
was hurt yeah but he's he switched teams
though dig with dolly no in garage sell
a grudge see now you know what it's like
to be part of the paparazzi t oh man you
know what I mean like that wasn't a good
feeling that's that technically I wasn't
a good feeling had that almost did
something to my ego but then I had to
like him I had to really kind of just
you know check my seven like okay yeah
you just hate I didn't get a response
and like dude I'm tio Kenny what are you
doing yeah exactly and I kind of felt
kind of it rebuilt bad to say Andre
Andre I got no response and he was like
literally like it was almost like I cuz
I do that sometimes
when I hear people call my name and I'm
like yeah I hear it but I don't hear it
right that's what he gave me and I
didn't really like that well it's not
just that uh Terrell it's it's also you
were holding Rich Eisen show Mike flag I
don't think that was the case you're not
the only one here who loves him some him
I love samee some me also okay okay and
if he's gonna say Andre Iguodala I'm
addressing camera for the radio audience
right now hundreds of good Iguodala look
what we're all excited that you're the
MV a MBP fob Finals MVP but that's
Terrell Owens over there he has almost
16,000 receiving yards second most all
time and I'm Rich Eisen of the Rich
Eisen char yeah and together we are not
to be blown off on the red carpet know
where the dynamic duo no not the boat
not blow both of us off am I your
quarterback is what you're saying
absolutely I'm our quarterback rich I
don't think there'll be any tears hey my
quarter but I've got your cereal from
Buffalo right over there oh my gosh
that's a throwback yeah I've got my tuck
out your cereal right here okay you got
the Syria ready you got the popcorn I do
what's next I don't know your clothing
Ronnie yeah that's why are you ready to
here pretty soon okay I'm a size large
for the zip up sleeveless polka dot
hoodie oh yeah and we're gonna do a
fashion show right here okay in the
meantime stay right there if you don't
mind me I want to talk to you about the
espy awards show itself okay and then
for a television only segment you'll be
the fashion police force as well oh yeah
okay Terrell Owens at Terrell Owens on
Twitter fresh off the ESPYs red carpet
back in just six and six in the clock I
noticed there are still a lot of phone
calls we'll get to as many of them as we
can in a moment
you
Terrell Owens here in person in studio
after hanging at the SPS last night so
what do you think of the award show
itself last night there's been a while
since I've been in probably like four or
five years but uh yeah I mean I think it
was a it was a great show I mean Joel
McHale he did his thing I think a lot of
the jokes kind of went over a lot of
people's head even my mmm uh but it was
it was fun which one which one do you
think there's a number my eye I just
didn't catch she didn't catch him now I
mean I'm really good with catching
things but I didn't catch the sum of
those jokes the one where he said that
Ronda Rousey's knocked out more women
than Bill Cosby we got that debt that we
got we got that one was wow yeah that
was something I think that was uh yeah
that was the best one of the night oh
sure yeah let's do that was part of his
monologue and then they had like a 34-30
based on how bad his monologue was that
was funny too but I'm just wondering
what is it like being an a-list
high-profile athlete being made fun of
by a comedian cuz it seems to me the
sense of humor level that athletes have
about themselves isn't very large it's
yeah but I think you have to be
confident in yourself and really you
have to realize that it comes with the
territory you subject yourself to I mean
just being in the limelight a lot of
criticism so anything that you may do I
mean for myself I mean now you have
social media with instagram twitter and
you got the means and you know you think
about all the things that i did you know
crying in the pictures you know i did to
think about the quarterback you know you
crying for Tony and and all those things
kind of pop up you know on the internet
so it's one of the things you just got
to take with a grain of salt you know
use rejected to to that type of uh you
know criticism some guys with the comedy
I mean they can be a little harsh yeah
you know just got to take it you know
you gotta just got to laugh laugh it off
and what about though that some of the
people in that room have been um trolled
is the word by some people on on ESPN
actually on ESPN
and this show up at an ESP right of that
is there any and again in a monkey cuz
your perfect example Yeah Yeahs perfect
exam I've been ticked off a few times of
you know some of the commentary but
you're able to put it aside to say that
that's one part of this conglomerate I'm
gonna come to the award show anyway yeah
and sometimes I there's been a couple of
times where you know some guys that have
been at that has worked for ESPN that
have been overly critical really just
not knowing all the facts and really
just trying to assess my character and
my personality and and really I think it
tarnished a little bit of my image you
know considering they knew nothing about
me and I've confronted a couple of them
mmm you know and you know that's just an
echo what out what did they what did
some of these folks well I know one
general i don't know if i should say his
name but I know his name rhyme with
Ellis no okay no I mean skipping me
skipper skipper mean he's an idiot I
mean again I mean sometimes I literally
was kind of like I was a good target
yeah form and sometimes I think he just
needed to say my name just to make
himself seem somewhat relevant um but
you know again it for an athlete to be
in that position I think it really hurts
the family more so than the then the
person himself or herself sure but yeah
the person that I confronted you know I
I I don't know if he know he definitely
didn't expect it but I didn't really
like what he had to say and I confronted
him and it was at it it was really it
was like some years ago with in Tampa it
was at a party and he was at this event
and I rolled up on him and he had some
wine in his hand and once I approached
him I think he kind of got nervous so he
started you know doing each one like
this and it spilled out of his out of
his glass uh-huh but uh yeah I mean I
approached the person I just told him I
didn't appreciate what he had to say and
it was you know the information that he
was putting out there was inaccurate
mm-hmm you know I didn't like it I'm
trying to think of all the wine drinkers
at ESPN that I know
going through my was a wider read was it
was it was it was it a Cabernet it was
red okay it was red cuz my buddy that
was wit me he even know he like do I
he'd like he was nervous did he listen
to you and did he catch you you were
saying and then she oh no no he know he
hurried what I had to say he continued
to say things on air on a negative light
or was he not enlightened I kind of
subsided a little bit but I mean I
wasn't like I said I wasn't trying to
threaten him or anything I just you know
for me it was just you know I didn't
like what he had to say because it was
almost like personal it was more
personal than anything I understand that
people have to be objective and
subjective with their jobs but I think
you it seemed a little bit more personal
than anything and that's the one thing
about being an athlete and playing a
sport and for myself I did a lot of
things that a lot of people misconstrued
as arrogance and for me I was a very
confident person on the football field
that was my passion that's what I exuded
and not made the comparison you know to
a number of guys that are still playing
now it's like you know how can you view
their passion different than mine and
it's pretty much the same thing right I
just depended the dependent on the
person and you know the likeability of
those two individuals and your your have
gone on and you're fine as an individual
and rush limbaugh's don't just find
himself right on me I'm gonna just start
throwing name or ESPN the thing is
considering what I what people thought
was bad in the league yeah it pales in
comparison to what's going on the last
five to ten years in terms of what what
do you mean in terms of things that you
know guys are doing off the field or you
know in terms of that character things
of that nature i mean what i did i mean
people viewed as bad for the game like i
celebrated I mean my passion if you
don't have a mic on the microphone or
you don't have access to what's being
said on the field everybody's going off
my gestures my mannerisms well everybody
saying that about debts too yeah
basically said in their in their
teammates have come out and supported
him in that too but did any at any point
in time when you were on the sideline
think to myself maybe I do tone it down
just a little bit because I know the
cameras are me
gonna take something out of context well
i did i've only done that maybe once or
twice you know i can remember one time
vividly was when we played the st. Louis
Rams and I was it was a Greg Knapp that
was that incident and I was really you
know I was going off on that because I
felt like I wasn't being involved in
orphans as I should and and I think a
lot of that was it boiled up because i
had my teammates on the sideline tell
him like dude tell him to get you the
ball i even had coaches like why aren't
you getting the ball so it was just a
series of of games that it just came to
a boiling point you know they like boot
it everybody else recognizes it you're
the offensive coordinator make it a
point so here we are in mid-july I'm
with Terrell Owens Oh would you let's
just put it this way would you if got
getting the phone calls somebody saying
we need some help up receiver and
training camp would you go ahead and do
that ready to line up [ __ ] uh-huh I'm
dead ended up Britain who the heck up
I'm always ready but you are one year
away from being eligible to be inducted
into the pro football hall of fame til
somebody asked me about that last night
think ah i was talking to aaron rodgers
last night okay and one of his he had a
I don't know if it's business partner a
good friend and he everybody kept like
dude you look like you're in great shape
like you can play I'm like yes not a
question that I I can play but I'm like
that's really not the issue people
factor in my age but I'm not the normal
40 year old or 41 year old I know that
there I could still be playing now given
the opportunity um but I mean people
bring up the Hall of Fame like I told
Aaron last night I'm like dude I'm like
I'd never played this game to go into
the Hall of Fame as i told you i think
the last time I never even imagined
planning beyond the collegiate level so
to have accomplished some of the things
that I've done in the football field and
be second or third behind the greatest
of all time dude that's in my mind it's
remarkable especially for kids because I
know when I was 13 14 and 15 year olds I
was skinny
like chef Curry said last night he like
I'm 61 whatever 180 pounds soaking wet
that's how it was coming out of high
school so I did whatever I could to get
bigger faster and stronger because my
peers around me was so much better than
I was and I wasn't fast I wasn't strong
but I did whatever I could to fit in to
get get some playing time because my
body had developed yet but if you you
know want to make a point to somebody
not that that's why you played as well
that you could be a first-ballot
hall-of-famer which is something that
not even people who were in the Hall of
Fame everyone can say and that moment
couldn't come for you next year you're
willing to put that six maybe seven
years down the road just to get a few
snaps in in the 2015 season but it
doesn't I don't I can't wrap my head
around the whole process like it because
it really literally doesn't mean that
much to me like I can I understand what
I've done on the field and probably it's
well deserving of that but again I don't
I'm being honest it really doesn't
bother me you know whether I get in or
not and I know a lot of people have had
this conversation like dude stop saying
that stop saying it I guess from a
standpoint of I guess a legacy or you
know what my kids can can can really see
what I've done the body of work and
appreciate it then yeah and my family
but me personally it really doesn't do
anything for me because I never played
it played the game for that I played it
because i was competitive i played it to
the point to where i realized my talents
and i became i became pretty good at it
and so that's that was my motivation I
wanted to win at all costs you know me
when I got to play with Jerry Rice and I
saw what he was able to do with the
quarterbacks in the team that he played
with I really wanted to take that to
another level I couldn't be Jerry but
there are some elements to his game
along with the physical makeup of my
body that I I put in my repertoire you
know I mean and I tried to be the best
that I could be you know taking a little
bit from jer's toolbox yep okay
it's not your fault that you had 20
catches on Jerry Rice day that's Steve
Mariucci is fault but people blame me
don't worry we get boots creep for that
all the time thanks for coming in here
tio and thanks for doing that the
correspondent stuff you are welcome like
I told you anytime please come back
anytime I enjoyed it thanks I'm doing it
it's over already well I'm not yet for
the TV audience you're gonna go through
the fashion police oh [ __ ] let's be all
right Terrell Owens is gonna stick
around for the TV on its don't you want
anywhere we're back with more on the
rich eisen shown
welcome back to the rich eisen show on
to thank my guests today Ian Rapoport
Pat 40 rich Lerner of the NFL media
group yahoo sports in golf channel
respectively and he's good to see you
too you you I wanted you to stick around
to finish the shop I am thank you here
let's take a phone lines Earl it real
quick Jeremy in Arizona you're on the
Rich Eisen show Jeremy hey rich yeah
Jeremy I've got about two minutes so
fire your question at E oh no what'd I
tell ya a big fan huge fan you if you're
a player hey um I just started playing
on fire up in a wildly remember your
dance brings hours on the Dow star after
Emmett's pregnant touch now he got
through runners I just think about you
know in the past you know you had your
gimmicks your games how you have only
have fun with each other I didn't feel
about that now yeah Jeremy thank you for
the call the t 0 star moment yeah I
probably do it again well we have our
answer there chef in California you're
on the rich eisen Josef we are rich my
mom met p 0 at the dry cleaner a few
years ago in west LA and she said he was
the most nice and considerate person tio
my mom knows nothing about football
hasn't been to a game since about
nineteen sixty two I'm just telling you
she is your biggest fan and rich know
you by the way I was at your book
signing it uh like a few years ago in
Beverly Hills right there we go and I've
been to the same dry cleaner as T oh so
it's the circle of life oh thanks a lot
thanks for the call sure there you go
tell your mom I said hello see you never
know when you go to the trunk all your
storage get uto or no yeah what do you
not know starter try dad yeah oh yeah
navigator can't go starch at the dry
cleaners can't have it that's what you
say Chris lobby like you go to the dry
cleaner go I haven't seen you would go
button down and I in quite some time
button down yesterday where you a button
down two days a week I go you know two
days a week Rich Eisen show calm you
want to finish the poll question
speaking of field who you got in the
open championship speed to the field 56%
jordan Spieth and Dustin Johnson still
leading cuz I haven't checked the
leaderboard in the in the last minute or
two here with Terrell Owens on the
program 7-under doesn't answer who's on
tomorrow's show we got a deal of
lien talented comedian Whitney Cummings
hi I'm an in-studio tits dude yeah we're
doing a some efforting already front
yeah what do you do it tomorrow valet
let me know it's got some popcorn ready
well good always keep it ready thank you
for thank you for coming in to you
thanks for havin uh yeah and and and uh
people know your number if they want you
to line up absolutely this is all I'm
starting become a regular on the rich
eisen show I like it be careful the
Andre where Don will start blowing you
off more ya know what is his malfunction
man I don't know I don't know you need
to work on this yeah it's alright we
can't have that sort of behavior come on
don't dre yeah me off like don't you
know who he is yeah tio don't you know
who the show is we love us some us you
blow off to yo you blow me off and on
his quarterback haha right that's right
thank you right thanks for coming back
what say you blow us off this really not
fair through one more time some fair can
blow us up Tony effect Who am I teal
it's my quarterback
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience